bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue sur LCP un
savourgarde spécial ce soir consacré à
l'attentat d'aras un professeur de
lettrre a été tué ce matin devant son
LCÉE l'assaillant a aussi poignardé deux
autres personnes le parallèle avec le
mode opératoire de l'assassinat Samuel
paatti saute aux yeux 3 ans presque jour
pour jour après sa décapitation la la
question des failles des services de
renseignement évidemment se pose
beaucoup de questions se posent ce soir
alors place au débat en direct avec nos
[Musique]
invités l'école une fois de plus en
deuillé dans notre pays l'attaque au
couteau s'est produite ce matin aux
abords du lycée Gambetta d'aras la
saillance en est pris à un professeur de
français une minute minute de silence a
été observé dans l'hémicycle vous le
voyez la représentation nationale qui
exprime sa peine sa compassion pour les
victimes et le chef de l'État qui
appelle à l'unité du
pays je suis là pour témoigner du
soutien de la
Nation pour dire que nous faisons bloc
et que nous tenons
debout bonsoir Mathieu Lefèvre merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député
renaissance du valdarne vous débattez ce
soir avec Jérôme g bonsoir B merci
d'être là vous êtes député socialiste de
lessonne bonsoir drisf bienvenue
spécialiste des questions de sécurité
docteur en droit public bonsoir pierre
connaisa merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes esséistes au fonctionnaire et vous
venez de publier un état des lieux du
salafisme en France du séparatisme au
terrorisme aux Éditions de l'Aube et
puis bonsoir Marco pommier Marco vous
avez passé votre journée à haras non
loin de ce lycée Gambetta vous allez
tout nous dire de l'atmosphère sur place
l'état d'esprit de ces élèves qui ont
été confinés pendant plusieurs heures de
leurs parents de leurs enseignants je
vous donne la parole à tous les quatre
dans quelques instants mais d'abord on
va faire le point sur les faits bien sûr
que sait-on exactement ce soir de cet
attentat terroriste on accueille
Stéphane blakovski pour nous le dire
tout de
suite bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Miriam
bonsoir messieurs alors les fait bien 3
ans après la mort de Samuel Patti un
professeur a de nouveau été assassiné en
France par un terr islamiste ça s'est
produit donc ce matin à 11h au lycée
Gambetta d'aras l'individu est âgé de 20
ans il a poignardé à plusieurs reprises
à la gorge un professeur qui est décédé
d'autres personnes se sont interposées
qui ont été blessé heureusement leur vie
n'est plus en danger alors qu'est-ce
qu'on sait à propos du tueur je vous
l'ai dit il a 20 ans il est d'origine
tchenenne de nationalité russe mais ce
qui a surtout frappé c'est que très
rapidement on a appris qu'il était
fichaise vous voyez là c'est apparu dans
la presse il était considéré donc comme
radicalisé et dangereux par la police
sous écoutes téléphonique avec même des
contrôles mais la police n'avait pas de
motif légal pour l'interpeller ce qui
fait qu'elle n'a pas pu le faire pour
compléter ce profil on peut ajouter
qu'il est arrivé en France avec sa
famille en 2008 il avait donc 6 ans et
ensuite assez rapidement en 2014 donc
les deux parents et les cinq enfants ont
fait l'objet d'une mesure d'expulsion
qui n'a pas été exécutée à la dernière
minute essentiellement sous la pression
d'association qui défendent de les
étrangers en situation irrégulière
finalement en 2018 le père de famille
lui a été expulsé puis l'année suivante
on est en 2019 l'un des frères a été
interpellé parce qu'il participait à un
projet d'attentat contre des policiers
et en 2021 le tueur lui avait demandé
une demande d'asile dans France qui lui
a été refusée mais il n'a pas été
expulsé parce que il est arrivé en
France avant l'âge de saison ce qui
constituait une protection euh légale
euh pour i euh voilà pour l'essentiel
défit si on veut ajouter les réactions
politiques évidemment indignation et
hommage ce sont aux victimes se sont
succédés quelques nuances malgré tout
vous voyez que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a bien
parlé de terrorisme évidemment pour cet
assassinat sans jamais prononcer le mot
islamiste une nuance avec François
Ruffin qui lui dénonce le terrorisme
islamiste qui frappe à nouveau la
République pour ce qui est des réactions
à droite une question
d'intensité sioti donc le P
DLR a demandé immédiatement au président
d'activer l'état d'urgence qui avait été
fait après le Bataclan tandis que
Jordane Bardella un cran au-dessus
demande carrément la démission de Gérald
daranin le ministre de l'Intérieur voilà
pour le résumé en grande ligne Géral
daranin s'exprime dans quelques minutes
au journal de TF1 on aura donc peut-être
d'autres éléments notamment avec
l'intervention du procureur absolument
ce sont au total h personnes qui sont en
garde à vue ce soir dont la saillante
bien sûr on sent tous qu'on est dans un
moment extrêmement sensible extrêmement
tendu il y a évidemment ce qui se passe
au au Proche Orient il y a les 3 ans de
l'assassinat de Samuel pti lundi dans
les collèges il doit y avoir normalement
on verra si c'est le cas ou pas une
minute de silence et c'est le scénario
du pire Mathieu lefèv qui frappe la
France est-ce que le gouvernement a
sous-évaluer la menace terroriste c'est
d'abord un moment de grande douleur et
je veux m'associer à tous les hommages
qui ont été rendus à ce professeur à la
communauté éducative et à nos forces de
l'ordre qui ont réagi avec une grande
promptitude aussi bien dans le Nord que
dans les ivelines président de la
République a doté le pays de moyens
inédits pour faire face à la menace
terroriste en doublant les moyens de nos
services de renseignement en augmentant
de près de 2000 les effectifs de nos
services de renseignement et grâce à eux
grâce à ces gens qui veillent sur nous
c'est une quarantaine d'attentats qui
ont été déjoués depuis 2017 maintenant
évidemment chaque drame est toujours un
échec euh et il faut le dire ainsi on ne
peut J il y a des questions qui se
posent ce soir hein vous le reconnaissez
il y a toujours des questions qui se
posent quand une vie humaine et une vie
française est fauchée singulièrement par
le terrorisme islamiste et il faut
mettre des mots sur les choses c'est un
attentat terroriste islamiste mais je
voudrais vous dire que la République ne
flanchira jamais face au terrorisme
islamiste on en a payé le prix on en a
payé lourdement le prix dans notre
histoire on continuera à le combattre et
à le combattre jusqu'à la mort il
cherchait un professeur Jérôme Gedge ça
on le sait les éléments de l'enquête
l'ont l'ont déjà montré il est AR
ce terroriste devant ce lycée en disant
je cherche le professeur d'histoire et
ça n'est pas un détail ce qui frappe
c'est la similitude avec l'assassinat de
Samuel paatti ça fait froid dans le dos
on a presque l'impression qu'au fond
pour les terroristes aujourd'hui
islamistes c'est le modèle à reproduire
cet assassinat
oui je pense que oui pour la simple
raison d'abord parce que ça
déclenche l'effroid et laassidération
dans dans dans le pays tous les
attentats évidemment ont cette charge
symbolique mais l'école comme sanctuaire
de la République comme lieu dans lequel
des jeunes sont en formation comme lieu
dans lequel c'est hussard noir de la
République que sont les enseignants sont
en cette mission magnifique de
transmission de formation du libre
arbitre de de de de passage des savoirs
et parfois aussi de
transmission de
ces valeurs républicaines Samuel paatti
on se rappelle des circonstances c'était
précisément parce que il avait fait cet
enseignement sur la liberté sur la
liberté d'expression c'est évidemment
c'est plus qu'un bras d'honneur à la
République c'est c'est une agression
frontale dans un de ces temples de la
République si j'ose dire tout le monde
redoutit ça mais est-ce que vous êtes
surpris c'est-à-dire que moi ce qui
m'effrait là au moment où on parle c'est
que c'est donc la deuxème fois en 3 ans
qu'un enseignant est
euh décapité égorgé
ou
frappé violemment par par
l'assaillant ce qui m'effrait c'est
qu'on pourrait presque comme on a eu sur
la répétition d'attentat intégrer que ça
peut devenir notre
quotidien et c'est ça qui me glace le
plus c'est-à-dire que on a eu d'autres
formes d'attentats ils sont là et puis
la vie continue et heureusement que la
vie continue et que la vie reprend parce
que c'est la meilleure réponse que nos
démocraties peuvent apporter à ceux qui
veulent précisément instiller le le
ferment de la de la haine de la division
de la colère parfois de la de la
vengeance donc c'est formidable d'être
résilient et de pouvoir dire et ben nous
continuons et nous ne cédons pas à cette
erreur et en même temps de se dire que
nous devons apprendre à vivre avec c'est
probablement ça qui est le plus
désespérant au moment où je parle il
reconnais ça est-ce que la menace était
beaucoup plus élevé euh depuis plusieurs
mois depuis quelques jours seulement euh
il y a aucun lien prouvé à ce stade de
de l'enquête entre ce jour de colère
appelé par le ramas aujourd'hui vendredi
jour de prière et cette attentat dans
cette école à haras mais est-ce que
depuis 3 qu plusieurs jours plusieurs
semaines la menace s'est
accru je sais pas je sais pas s'il faut
faire le lien entre la situation
internationale et cet acte
qui est quand même très très ciblé et
très français dans son dans son propos
dans sa son ciblage dans le le principe
même de de l'anniversaire de la mort de
Samuel paatti je crois qu'il faut pas
diluer complètement le sujet moi ce qui
m'inquiète beaucoup plus c'est que on
avait comme pour Samuel paatti
exactement tous les critères qui se sont
répétés on avait une famille radicalisée
le gosse arrive ici le jeune Mohamed
mogoukov arrive ici à 5 ans et il a fait
son assassinat à 20 ans c'est-à-dire
qu'il s'est radicalisé dans sa sa
famille c'est pas l'école républicaine
qui l'a radicalisé exactement comme
anzorov pareil la famille é l'objet
d'une menace d'qutf alors parler des
occup obligation à quitter le territoire
français comment dire macaron
macaronnade inutile et et au lieu de les
expulsé si vous voulez on les conserve
sur le territoire parce que toutes les
garanties judiciaires leur sont
accordées y compris le fait que c ils
ont des enfants effectivement donc on
est sur quelque chose où on a répéter
les mêmes erreurs et on a le même
résultat donc au-delà de la tristesse de
la peine sur qu'on partage tous il faut
quand même en tirer des leçons qui soni
un peu plus radicales c'est l'échec de
qui alors pour vous bah c'est l'échec du
système c'est quoi systè pourquoi cette
famille n'at-elle pas pu expulser parce
que quand vous allez raconter ça à la
famille du professeur on va vous
expliquer que l'État de droit mais
l'état de droit on s'adapte moi j'ai été
juge je sais qu'il faut on peut adapter
la jurisprudence et on peut adapter le
droit donc il y a la responsabilité du
politique alors manifestement 2014 il y
a un contexte c'est celui de leonarda ça
n'excuse rien il y a des des
associations à l'époque où cette arrêté
préfectoral est pr en ven le MP
notamment et d'autres de défense du
droit d'asile qui pèsent pour que cette
famille ne le soit pas et évidemment il
y a des recours qui ont été utilisés qui
ont qui ont qui ont pris du temps oui
mais il reste que si vous voulez les
associations humanitair qui défendent le
droit d'asile doivent faire un examen
critique moi je peux vous citer des
exemples ils ont pris la défense de gens
qui étaient internés en Syrie racontant
qu'ils étaient malades qu' fallait qu'il
soit soigner il s'appelle ousama hatar
très exactement dès qu'il est rapatrié
en France il disparaît on le retrouve en
Tunisie en train de faire du trafic
d'armes et il est emporté à notre
affection par un DRAM américain en Syrie
je veux dire quand on a défendu ce genre
de situation sans même se demander s'il
y avait véritablement lieu de le
rapatrier il y a que amnestie qui soit
excusé en disant mais nous nous avons
demandé qu'il soit soigné pas qu'il soit
rapatrié donc il y a au moment chez les
ONG aussi à demandé si vous voulez à se
rendre compte qu'on peut pas tout n'est
pas défendable on peut pas rester sur
les principes il faut de temps en temps
confronter ses principes à la réalité on
a l'impression que le gouvernement sur
cette affaire il y a plusieurs questions
qui se pose he il y a la question
d'expulsion en 2014 il la question de
l'expulsion de ce suspect aujourd'hui
qui a 20 ans et qui était fich drev il
est fich il est même radicalisé fichier
pour radicalisation expliquez-nous ce
que ça veut dire il était sur écoute il
a même fait l'objet d'un contrôle et son
suivi n'a pas permis de l'empêcher de
passer à l'acte c'est c'est vrai que
c'est toujours compliqué d'abord je
pense que c'est bien de de préciser il y
a aussi beaucoup de de de réfugi il est
arrivé avant ses 13 ans sur le
territoire il y en a beaucoup qui
arrivent avant l'âge de 13 ans et qui
s'enerent parfaitement bien et qui sont
extrêmement fiers deê d'êt français et
donc tout tout ça pour dire que la
difficulté elle vient aussi d'une
radicalisation sur notre territoire donc
il faut aussi qu'on soit lucide et qu'on
regarde aussi la situation dans notre
territoire je vrais aussi préciser la
famille est arrivée en en 2008 donc et
lui est arrivé à moins 13 ans lui avait
5 6 ans oui voà et donc quand on prend
effectivement les attentats depuis même
2012 la plupart exception fait ces
derniers terroristes sont des individus
qui sont nés sur le territoire de la
République ont fréquenté les écoles de
la République et qui sont à un moment
donné retourner contre la République
donc c'est aussi important de regarder
avec lucidité l'état d'une partie de
notre jeunesse qui est radicaliser ceux
qui sont en prison qui sont emprisonnés
la plupart d'entre eux ce sont des
Français s'agissant ensuite
effectivement sur la situation qu'on
évoque il y a c'est vrai une vraie
difficulté à un moment donné pour les
services de renseignement il faut
l'admettre notamment lorsqu'on est ce
qu'on appelle en police administrative
pourquoi parce qu'on dit oui
effectivement il était fichier s il
était sur écoute il était même suivi oui
et le contrôle d'un service de police
normal diligeanté par la DGSI la réalité
c'est qu'il a été opéré pour s'assurer
qu'il avait pas d'armes peut-être
collectter un nombre de renseignement et
cetera pour les services c'est toujours
très difficile lorsque par exemple le 26
septembre dernier dans le sud de la
France la DGSI avec sous le contrôle du
parquet national antiterroriste ont
interpellé un individu qu'ils ont
immédiatement placé en détention
provisoire parce qu'il y avait
suffisamment d'éléments pour les
services de renseignement afin de
judiciariser je rappelle que nous avons
nous une infraction en France qui
n'existe c'est vrai nulle par
association de malfaiteurs terroristes
qui permet de prévenir quelquefois la
préparation un acte terroriste donc
c'est une disposition pénale qui est
importante pour nous et pour autant on
le dit on le dira jamais assez le risque
zéro n'existe pas vous savez pour
terminer aujourd'hui environ la DGSI
c'est 5000 personnes vous avez des
fichiers S qui sont aujourd'hui suivis
vous en avez à peu près 100000
5300 terroristes islamistes vous avez à
peu près 3000 de l'ultra gauche et 1500
de l'ultra droite il faudrait 8000
personnes donc la DGSI c'est dire 3000
agents de plus pour pouvoir couvrir la
totalité de ces personnels ce qui est
extrêmement le manque de moyens de la
police qui lui a permis d'échapper à une
véritable surveillance le manque de
moyens et de temps parce que la DGSI
lève le doute sur un individu et ils
sont obligés de passer sur un autre
dispositif pour s'assurer qu'il y a pas
de menace alors on reprend ce ce débat
et on y est sur la question des failles
sur la question des solutions il y a des
projets de loi qui arrivent notamment
sur l'immigration on va y venir mais
d'abord on va rejoindre Marco Pomier
bonsoir Marco à nouveau racontez-nous un
petit peu cette cette journée aux abord
du lycée Gambetta j'imagine que vous
avez rencontré à la fois des enseignants
peut-être des parents des des élèves
dans quel état d'esprit sont-ils
j'imagine toujours choqué ce soir
oui Miriam plus de
après les fait l'émotion est toujours
très forte ici ce soir à haras après
l'effroid et l'horreur nous on se trouve
juste devant les lieux du drame devant
le lycée Gambetta juste à côté aussi de
la cellule psychologique qui a été mise
en place pour le personnel éducatif et
les élèves toute l'après-midi on a pu
voir aux alentours de l'établissement et
bien des parents extrêmement inquet qui
ont retrouvé leurs enfants qui avaient
parfois du mal à réaliser certains
étaient même en pleur dans les bras de
leurs parents il faut imaginer
l'angoisse qu'ils ont vécu ce matin aux
alentours de 11h certains ont vu
l'agression mortelle de par les vitres
de leur classe d'autres n'ont rien vu
mais ils ont entendu entendu les cris
les sirènes de la police ils ont entendu
aussi et bien l'alarme de
l'établissement qui a retenti pour les
alerter du danger et puis d'autres et
bien sont restés confinés pendant de
longues heures dans leur classe dans
leur salle de classe je vous propose
d'écouter le témoignage les témoins
plutôt d'un d'un enseignant d'un d'un
professeur de philosophie ici de dans
l'établissement et mais aussi d'un
collégien et de son et de son père à la
sortie de la cellule de crise et c'était
bizarre parce qu'en fait j'étais en
permanence je suis descendu et j'ai vu
ça j'ai vu le ce qu'il y a eu je veux
pas trop m'en parler parce que c'est
c'est un choc quand votre fils est en 5e
là au lycée Gambetta et que en fait il
vous appelle et il me dit qu'il y a un
attentat bien sûr j'étais inquiet
inquiet aujourd'hui j'ai maintenant là
j'ai j'ai plus de la colère en fait la
colère envers le gouvernement en colère
parce que il y a il y a rien eu de fait
depuis monsieur paatti bah on porte le
deuil de ce collègue voilà euh on est
dans des relations amicales très
confraternelles dans ce dans cet
établissement euh il y a des des très
belles occasions de se voir organisé par
l'amical de l'établissement donc c'est
un établissement qui qui vit et euh dans
lequel il y a pas de tension on
en état de choc effectivement on est on
est bouleversé par ce qui se passe on
réalisera petit à petit que ce sera sans
doute long à cicatrisé qui faudra du
temps pour pour recréer des conditions
normales
d'apaisement voilà myiam vous l'avez
compris ce soir il y a encore beaucoup
d'émotion mais aussi de la colère devant
cet établissement d'aras alors que la
police scientifique est toujours sur
place merci à tout à l'heure Marco
Pomier ma tu faire il y a il y a des
réponses à apporter ne serait-ce qu'à
ses parents on entend cette cette colère
si on reprend un tout petit peu les le
contexte de cette famille parce que
c'est pas rien quand même le père a été
expulsé en 2018 pour violence conjugale
le grand frère est en prison pour
association de malfaiteurs terroristes
impliqué dans un projet d'attentat
contre l'Élysée en 2019 on l'a dit la
saillant fich s radicalisé sur écoute en
2014 cette initiative cette arrêté
d'expulsion qui finalement ne sera pas
exécuté il va y avoir beaucoup de
réponses à donner vous savez que ce soir
le rassemblement national demande la
démission de gerérald armanin qu'est-ce
que vous répondez d'abord je pense que
dans des circonstances pareilles on
devrait pas se livrer à la moindre
polémique je pense que le temps est
d'abord au deuil et et au recueillement
en revanche évidemment que il faut des
réponses évidemment que cette colère si
tantit qu'elle puisse être apaisée doit
pouvoir l'être avec des explications et
des
explications rationnelles et très cage
du ministère dit qui ne pouvait pas être
expulsé pour être très précis parce
qu'il avait moins de 13 ans au moment de
son arrivée en France c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'excuse de minorité le verrou
de minorité c'est ça exactement c'est ce
qu'on appelle une protection à à à au
regard notamment de son arrivée sur le
territoire national c'est pr faut
conserver ça ou il faut changer ça c'est
précisément ce que vise à à supprimer le
projet de loi immigration que porte le
ministre de l'intérieur de la même
manière que sur les recours contentieux
vous évoquez monsieur les associations
qui ont formulé de nombreux recours
évidemment qu'il faut avoir un droit de
recours évidemment qu'il faut pouvoir
s'opposer à la décision de la
juridiction administrative mais
siour ça n'est pas possible il y a des
gens dont on sait qu'ils n'ont rien à
faire sur le territoire national on ne
doit pas donner plus de moyens
juridiques à ceux qui veulent défendre
des gens qui n'ont rien à faire sur le
territoire national qu'à ceux qui ont
vocation à intégrer la la République
parce qu'il la il la respectent mais
vous savez ministre de l'intérieur sous
l'autorité du Président de la République
mène une politique extrêmement ferme
depuis des années ça fait 800 personnes
extrêmement dangereuses qui ont été
expulsées du territoire national depuis
maintenant plusieurs années le ministre
de l'Intérieur place en centre de
rétention administrative les profils les
plus dangereux précisément pour qu'on
puisse les expulser le plus rapidement
possible il faut évidemment aller plus
loin notamment en augmentant les places
de rétention administrativ mais on peut
parvenir à ce que ça s'arrête
franchement Jérôme Gedge le le président
dit la nation doit faire bloc vous allez
répondre à son à son appel d'unité
est-ce qu'il faut de des mesures
supplémentaires il y a une loi sur le
séparatisme maintenant il y a des
perquisitions administratives possibles
il y a toute une série de choses qu'il
est poss possible de faire on essaie de
réduire les délais de recours pour les
les expulsions vous le socialiste ce
soir vous dites quoi qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire encore une nouvelle loi alors
d'abord quand le président dit que la
nation doit faire bloc moi je le
soutiens évidemment parce que le
première intention de la terreur partout
où elle se répand c'est de créer la
dissension à l'intérieur de la
communauté nationale donc l'urgence du
moment et je veux pas éluder toutes les
questions de fond que vous posez c'est
d'abord de s'assurer euh que la cohésion
nationale soit maintenue nous sommes
dans un moment inflammable vous l'avez
dit ça intervient au terme d'une semaine
où l'émotion est évidemment elle était
planétaire après ce qui s'est passé en
Israël et au regard de ce qui se passe
en Israël et on voit bien qu'il y a tous
les ingrédients pour une forme
de d'émotion exacerbée sur laquelle tout
est possible voilà moi au moment où je
vous parle je suis extrêmement inquiet
parce que il peut y avoir la logique de
vengeance la logique
d'instrumentalisation la logique de de
de de de cristallisation et donc le
premier temps là dans l'urgence et on va
répondre aux questions législatives qui
forcément se pose avec une autre
temporalité c'est d'abord d'assurer les
conditions de sécurité moi j'ai
confiance dans les forces de police et
dans les directives qui leur sont donnés
il faut sécuriser les écoles les lieux
de culte mais avec cette dimension
insupportable c'est que de toute façon
on pourra jamais assurer c'est terrible
ce que je vais
dire le risque zéro moi j' j' app comme
moi le
passé regardé la famille et vous avez
regardé le fait que on est là devant un
russe d'origine che Chen qui est déjà
radicalisé qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça je je encore une fois c'est une
question de moyen là l'urgence c'est que
ça ne dégénère pas dans le pays voilà je
vous le dis cigz le plus je crains soit
un phénomène de mimétisme avec le
contexte de reproduction je crains un
phénomène de vengeance avec pour parler
très concrètement des actes de nature
tout aussi terroriste contre des
musulmans vivant en France et donc cette
espèce de surenchère et de guerre civile
ou en tous les cas d'ambiance qui
participe donc là c'est d'une certaine
manière l'urgence à laquelle chaque
citoyen doit être associé de vigilance
de sécurisation et de responsabilité
c'est pour ça que chaque parole compte
et donc pour répondre enfin à votre
question évidemment qu'il faut tirer les
conséquences euh il y a des failles
incontestablement dans une immigration
sur ce fameux V oui mais alors vous
voyez rebondis on arrive en France avant
13 ans on ne peut plus être expulsé
c'est ça en gros est-ce qu'il faut
changer ça si il y a des dispositions
dans le droit des étrangers qui
constituent des failles qui n'ont pas
permis d'assurer euh dans de bonnes
conditions cette sécurité sans être
généralisé vous voyez bien parce que
vous entendez soioti en disant c'est la
conséquence de l'immigration ou le
rassemblement national c'est la
submersion je dire on voit bien les
instrumentalisations indécentes qui vont
pouvoir avoir lieu ce que vous avez dit
à l'instant est très juste les autres
attentats commis en France le problème
c'est l'islamisme le problème c'est la
radicalisation qui peut frapper des
Français nés sur le territoire français
euh voir même fr par de djihadisme
d'atmosphère est-ce qu'on peut lutter
contre ça le djihadisme d'atmosphère
alors notamment Pierre connais ça des
des réseaux sociaux qui amplifient la
haine est-ce que c'est un combat
gagnable ou perdu d'avance et avec quels
outils oui on peut le combattre
simplement il faut pas réagir simplement
parce qu'il y a un attentat en 2021 je
crois il y a eu 627 cas dans l'école
nation dans la l'école républicaine de
contestation de l'enseignement de toute
nature refus d'enseignement refus d'être
assis à côté d'une fille enfin donc il y
a une espèce de forme de séparatisme qui
n'a cessé de s'amplifier contre lequel
on a toujours réagi en en reculant en
disant c'est est si grave c'est le
sous-titre de mon bouquin la deuxème
remarque dans les fichiers s aujourd'hui
le haut de gamme c'est-à-dire ceux qui
sont les plus dangereux qui est 14 les
critères 14 à 7 ils ont environ 4000
personnes pour surveiller un type comme
celui-là il faut entre 10 et 20
policiers alors vous faites le calcul
4000 x par 20 ça veut dire qu'il
faudrait 80000 policiers supplémentaires
donc arrêtons il faut vider le stock et
vider le stock ça veut dire qu'il faut
expulser par principe de précaution et
non pas une fois que l'attenta est
commise il faut expulser et vider un
certain nombre de gens qui
sonttiellement dangereux préc pour vous
qui les fichiers S c'est ce que réclame
le rassemblement national il y en a
30000être que c'est rensemblement
national M administrativ attendez là on
a le cas d'un blocage juridique d'une
famille qui était considérée comme
dangereuse qui va finalement par
produire quelqu'un qui va assassiner un
enseign là c'était une autre fiche il
était radicalisé ça fait partie il y a
une distinction entre les fiches
administratives et et les fich du
fichier fsprt c'est ça fsprt ouais tout
à
fait
une famille qui qu'on n pas pu expulser
parce que c'est très compliqué de de
parvenir à au risque zéro c'est c'est
expulser tous les fichiers c'est ça que
propose non pas du tout il y a il y a 16
critères dans les les fichiers ceux qui
sont les plus graves évidemment c'est
ceux qui sont le haut de gamme il y en a
environ 3 4000 3 4000 dont celui-ci qui
devait être surveillé normalement
c'était une une surveillance euh
rapprochée enfin c'était mais vousz
imaginez bien que l'écouter au téléphone
si le type est pas idiot il va pas dire
au téléphone je vais faire un attentat
donc c'est pas ça le problème le
problème encore une fois c'est de vider
le stock des gens qui sont les plus
dangereux nos forces de police sont
obligées de protéger 50 à 60
personnalités qui sont menacées de mort
plus surveiller les écoles juives plus
surveiller maintenant les écoles
républicaines ça veut dire qu'on va
faire une force de police statique et
celle-là ne pourra plus faire de la
l'investigation donc je reviens sur
quelque chose les blocages juridiques
des octf aujourd'hui sont un véritable
problèmee une question non mais jeux fr
juste une question mais et je suis
d'accord sur la dimension préventive
voilà mais les tous les fichiers S ne
sont pas étrangers ah bah oui bien sûr
bien sûr comment fait pour les fichers s
radicalisé qui ne sont pas étrangers et
pour lesquels vider le stock pour
reprendre cette image n'est pas
opérationnelf il y a il y a ce que ce
que vient dire jérô tout à fait juste
c'est que vous avez une partie quand
même des fichises qui sont français et
donc il est extrêmement compliqué
d'expulser un français c'est même pas
possible c'est son territoire
expliquez-nous la différence entre et
alors le le le fichiers en réalité c'est
un outil de travail quand c'est une
balise c'est une balise qu'on pose sur
l'état civil d'un individu lorsque vous
passez par exemple à la police aux
frontières le policier il a dans son
écran madame YM en Kawa donc elle fichs
et il y a une conduite à tenir
c'està-dire vous posz un certain nombre
de questions prendre sans attirer votre
attention savoir avec qui vous voyagez
d'où vous venez où est-ce que vous allez
comment vous êtes habillé et cetera et
cetera donc c'est un outil de
renseignement qui permet effectivement
de vous suivre un petit peu c'est pas un
outil qui témoigne d'une certaine forme
de dangerositéut c'est un outil de
renseignement lorsqu'un individu est
fichiers ou qu'il est au fsprt ce n'est
quelquefois pas un j'ai envie de dire
une raison objective quelque fois pour
la justice administrative ou pour
l'autorité préfectorale l'autorité
administrative pour vous retirer un
titre de cheisour et vous vous expulsez
donc quelque fois c'est extrêmement
compliqué effectivement à corréler les
deux donc c'est vrai qu'il y a un vrai
travail à faire le travail je crois
qu'il est fait par le ministre de
l'intérieur comme tous les derniers
ministres de l'Intérieur successif de
droite comme de gauche je pense qu'on
peut pas dire qu'on a eu un ministre de
l'Intérieur de droite ou de gauche l'xis
sur ce sujetl ils ont tous à cœur de
protéger effectivement la République et
puis les Français je pense qu'ils le
font en revanche il faut dire que c'est
du temps long un ministre de l'Intérieur
qui prend en France sur les TF et dans
tous les pays c'est lonc mais c'est du
temps long parce qu'on travaille sur de
l'humain le ministre de l'Intérieur qui
arrive en prenant ses fonctions et qui
dit moi demain je a le terroriste le le
terrorisme en France et ben ce n'est pas
la vérité parce qu'on touche à de
l'humain ce sont des trajectoires qui
sont prenez le le cas de ces prisonniers
ou de ces individus aujourd'hui en
prison soit qui sont radicalisés ou qui
sont effectivement enfermés pour
terrorisme ils vont bien sortir un jour
d'ailleurs ils sortent vous en avez 350
d'or moment on se parle cette année vous
en avez 80 qui vont sortir vous en avez
78 79 qui vont sortir l'année prochaine
donc on va les suivre pendant un an et
ensuite la loi ne permet plus de les
suivre sauf si il pose une vraie menace
donc le danger ne disparaît pas pour
autant cette idéologie islamiste il faut
la combattre on la combat aussi à
l'école pour ça qu'effectivement ils
s'en prennent à l'école je rappelle
qu'and en Afghanistan la première chose
que les talibans font au-delà de la
restauration de la charia c'est la
fermeture des établissements hein parce
que pour eux c'est pas bon et donc il
fais aussi à l'école les question la
parentalité le président de la
République l'a très très justement dit
et c'est une convergence de politique
publique où la sécurité n'est pas le
seul indicateur n'est pas le le le n'est
pas la seule politique et pendant que
vous débattez messieurs ellisabeth borne
selon nos confrères de BFM TV vient de
déclarer l'urgence l'alerte urgente
attentat donc on on monte d'un cran euh
dans dans l'alerte et et le procureur
rappelle le bilan un mort donc on le
sait ce professeur de lettrre et non pas
deux mais trois blessés pour terminer
Mathieu Lefèvre on voit qu'il va y avoir
sur ce qui s'est passé sur les fait
beaucoup de réponses à apporter et
au-delà euh quelles sont quelles sont
les réponses que vous allez commencer à
construire aujourd'hui vous en avez une
idée cette loi immigration va permettre
quoi concrètement est-ce que cet
attentat avec cette loi parce qu'on a
tellement de lois ne se serait pas
produit j'aurais pas la pré inention de
dire que cette loi aurait permis
d'éviter cet attentat en revanche dans
cette loi il y a la suppression de la
protection précisément pour les
personnes qui sont arrivées sur le sol
national avant leur 13 ans il y a la
réduction des recours administratifs
précisément dans cas de d'expulsion il y
a également la création de 3000 places
de rétention administrative qui sont
essentielles précisément pour des
étrangers clandestins qui n'ont rien à
faire sur le territoire national il y a
près de 70 % des expulsions qui sont
précédés d'un placement en rétention
administrative il faut être lucide et on
devra collectivement tirer toutes les
conséquences à la fois juridiques et
politiques de ce drame comment on l'a
fait d'ailleurs après l'assassinat audio
de Samuel pti on a créé un délit de
séparatisme on a renforcé la protection
de nos professeurs on a également fait
en sorte de mieux contrôler les lieux de
culte leur financement on doit
évidemment aller plus loin en ce sens
bon on verra si l'opposition est au
rendez-vous de de l'unité nationale on
vous réinvitera pour ce débat vous ne
savez pas si vous voterez tout ça pour
le moment j'imagine d'un mot pour
conclure on on soutiendra évidemment
celles des mesures qui sont au service
de la protection de l'ensemble de nos
conitoyens dans la limite de la fuite en
avant et d'une forme de de
généralisation qui poserait problème je
le redis ce soir c'est Dominique Bernard
je veux qu'on recite son nom parce celui
de Samuel paatie et et et se dire on en
arrive à ce que les enseignants j'ai
échangé avec beaucoup enseignant cet
après-midi ce ce sont évidemment
meurtris de comprendre que cela est
désormais un phénomène qui peut se
reproduire et qu'ils sont devenus des
cibles possibles pour ceux qui veulent
s'attaquer à travers eux à la République
on va en parler à présent de la
communauté enseignante on s'arrête là
pour ce premier plateau merci beaucoup
vous restez avec nous pierre connaisa
l'école ce sanctuaire a donc été meurtri
une seconde fois c'est une onte de choc
pour ces enseignants qui risquent
désormais de redouter
chaque 16 octobre on voit cela avec hélè
Bonduel la saillant d'aras Mohamed
mogoukov cherchait-il à reproduire le
meurtre de Samuel paatti à marqué cet
anniversaire funeste fiché s il faisait
l'objet d'écoute et de surveillance sans
pour autant éveiller les soupçons de ce
meurtre comme l'agresseur de Samuel
paatti il y a 3 ans presque jour pour
jour Mohamed mogoukov est d'origine
tchenne mais de nationalité russe
abdouah kzorov le terroriste de Conflant
saintonorine était en revanche de
nationalité française deux jeunes hommes
t deux radicalisés il y a 3 ans Samuel
pati était assassiné après avoir
présenté des caricatures de Mahomet à
ses élèves collégiens ce matin selon ce
professeur de philosophie qu'il a croisé
la saandarace n'était pas là par hasard
ce moment l'agresseur quandme retourn
vers moi voyant que je m'étais avancé
que je commence à lui parler il m'a dit
vous êtes professeur d'histoire vous es
prof d'histoire et m' voilà m'a
poursuivi
pour voilà pour parce que j'avais
cherché à m'interposer donc j'ai été
effectivement poursuivi pendant quelques
minutes ce sera finalement un professeur
de français qui mourra sous ses coups de
couteau deux autres personnels de
l'établissement sont gravement blessés
un drame qui ravive les blessures à
Conflant saintonorine où enseigner
Samuel Patti alors qu'un hommage
national devait lui être rendu lundi
prochain on n'est pas serein euh on peut
se dire voilà ça peut arriver encore à
tout moment enfin voilà hein et tr s'est
passé exactement la même chose du coup
on se dit peut-être c'est une
organisation ou quelque chose qui a été
organisé donc bah i ça fait forcément
peur peut-être ils peuvent revenir ici
on sait jamais lorsqu'on vient à l'école
on vient pas on vient pour étudier et
pas pour survivre enfin et ça fait assez
peur de venir et de se dire que
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui il aura un
attentat ou pas des parents et des
élèves qui se félicitent que les
ministres de l'éducation nationale et de
l'Intérieur annonc un renfort de
sécurité devant les établissements
scolaires et nous ont rejoint sur ce
plateau Bruno miliet bonsoir député
MoDem desvelines bonsoir michaell
taverern député rassemblement national
du Nord bonsoir àain sexi vous êtes
inspecteur d'académie honoraire et
membre du conseil des sages de la
laïcité vous allez on va en parler parce
que ça tous les signalement vous vous
remonte donc vous avez une bonne idée du
terrain et de ce qui se passe dans dans
nos établissements scolaires et pu
reconnait ça bien sûr et rester avec
nous Stéphane Simon auteur de l'enquête
sur les derniers jours de Samuel paatti
paru chez plomb vous vous en souvenez
sûrement qui avait permis à Michel Patti
la sœur de Samuel paatti de de rendre
publque une une lettre dont vous aviez
été l'intermédiaire merci d'être avec
nous je vais commencer tout de suite
avec l'enseignant que vous êtes et avec
et avec vous Stéphane Simon c'est le
cauchemar qui reprend monsieur sexic ça
recommence j'aimerais vraiment
comprendre quel sentiment vous a
traversé aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
êtes en colère ce soir est-ce que vous
êtes abattu est-ce que c'est c'est un
chagrin profond et et quel et quel est
le sentiment de vos collègues que vous
avez dû avoir en ligne écoutez c'est
j'ai éprouvé tous les sentiments que
vous venez d'énoncer c'est c'est
l'abattement terrible et puis bien sûr
le la colère et l'envie malgré tout de
de continuer à affirmer nos valeurs au
effort et qu'on soit nombreux et qu'on
soit tous à le faire je crois que s'il y
a un mot d'ordre à lancer aujourd'hui
c'est tous avec notre République tous
notre pour notre République et tous avec
son école voilà c'est toute la nation
avec son école aujourd'hui oui alors
bien sûr il y a y a beaucoup de
battement mais en même temps il y a pas
fondamentalement de d'étonnement si vous
voulez vous n'êtes pas surpris non parce
que il y a déjà eu Samuel paatti on
pouvait espérer qu'il n'y en aurait pas
d'autres malheureusement nous étions
nombreux à penser que ça pouvait arriver
encore ça pouvait arriver encore on va
revenir sur l'état d'esprit des
enseignants la peur l'autocensure il y a
une minute de silence hein mais qui
arrive lundi normalement oui lundi je
voudrais dire en 30 secondes pourquoi il
y a pas d'étonnement à proprement parler
c'est que nous savons que la cible
essentielle des islamistes de manière
générale c'est l'Occident se de
l'Occident c'est la République française
et au sein de la République française
c'est son école c'est la cible
principale les les islamistes eux savent
très bien l'importance de l'école pour
notre nation il y a que nous pour pour
l'ignorer pour ne pas la défendre
complètement c'est la cible principale
tous les travaux de Bernard Rougier
d'Hugo Micheron de Gilles kpel avant
nous le disent Stéphane Simon j'aimerais
savoir si vous avez parlé avec des
membres de la famille de Samuel Patti
c'est le cauchemar c'est le scénario du
pire pour eux on l'IM imagine notamment
Michel Patti qui avait alerté qui avait
appelé un sursaut républicain est-ce
qu'elle vous a parlé
aujourd'hui on a échangé quelques mots
sur sur sur messagerie mais vous
comprenez qu'elle est dans un état
d'abattement qui ne laisse pas beaucoup
de place à de longs de longues tirades
et à des des bavardages je crois que
pour cette famille c'est le cauchemar
qui recommence et ça c'est absolument
terrible je j'abonde dans dans au propos
qui viennent d'être tenus vous vous vous
souvenez quand je suis venu vous voir au
mois de d'avril ou mai je ne sais plus
exactement à quelle période vous m'aviez
invité vous m'aviez demandé si oui ou
non l'affaire l'assassinat de Samuel
paatti pouvait pouvait reprendre pouvait
recommencer et je vous avais dit oui il
n'y a aucune raison que ça ne recommence
pas malheureusement j'aurais aimé me
tromper là il se trouve que vous
comprenez que notre République n'a pas
su tirer les enseignements
malheureusement de l'assassinat de
Samuel paatti alors quel enseignement
précis et qu'est-ce qu'elle a raté notre
République précisément selon vous bah
quand quand quand vous vous penchez sur
le les 11 jours qui ont précédé
l'assassinat de Samuel pati vous voyez
bien tout ce qui dfonctionne vous voyez
bien que les les procédures de
signalement ne sont pas pardon j'espère
que vous m'entendez
toujours oui pardon excusez-moi les
procédures de de de signalement ne sont
pas c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire
d'une d'une très grande fluidité euh par
ailleurs il y a tellement de
signalements que tout ça devient un peu
inopérant puisque trop d'alarme tuent
l'alarme vous connaissez le principe et
puis euh il y a aussi dans la détection
et ça c'est plutôt du travail et du
ressort de
l'antiterrorisme il y a beaucoup trop de
trous dans la raquette euh les les les
les candidats au djihad comme était
Abdullah kanzerov qui faisait savoir au
effort sur les messageries diverses et
variées a été signalé 17 fois sur la sur
la plateforme Faros et personne euh au
sein de la dcriri n'a pris le garçon au
sérieux je pense que l'affaire n'a n'a
pas été traité sinon elle aurait été
évidemment traitée différemment il faut
aussi se rappeler que dans le cas précis
de Samuel Patti il y avait une menace
qui était extrêmement précise contre lui
contre l'établissement il aurait pu y
avoir une procédure d'éloignement pour
pour Samuel alors vous reconnaissez que
ce ce deuxième attentat à haras c'est
très différent mais il cherchait un
professeur d'histoire brunoen c'est ça
qui glace c'est que au fond c'est dans
le sillage de cette décapitation que ce
terroriste voulait s'inscrire il
cherchait un professeur d'histoire oui
mais bien sûr ça a été rappelé enfin
notre école est la première cible parce
que parce que notre école ça aide tout
le monde à devenir un citoyen éclairé
parce que notre école est sûrement dans
l'éveil en tout cas du citoyen une des
meilleures du monde et moi je suis fils
de prof j'ai j'ai eu ma mère au
téléphone elle est elle est elle est à
la retraite maman elle est désespérée
enfin vous imaginez bien que toute cette
communauté moi je veux leur rendre
hommage euh
après c'est compliqué d'imaginer il
était suivi par le DGSI ce le criminel
oui on en a beaucoup parlé avec Pierre
conis ça tout à fait il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de question sur su regardez
dans le même temps vous avez deux cas en
parallèle vous avez ce qui est arriv à
ras avec le drame qu'on connaît et qui
nous a tous glacé desffroid et puis vous
avez exactement la même chose à peu près
au mêmes heures à limé suivi de la même
façon lui il a été
arrêté moi je suis pas dans les ivelines
effectivement un individu qui sortait la
mosquée avec une arme blanche et qui a
été arrêté avant de pénétrer policier
mais j'imagine bien que quand vous avez
des gens sur écoute d'abord ça a été
rappelé dans vos avec vos précédents
invités on peut pas mettre 20 policiers
par fichers s radicalisé les fameux 4000
dont vous parliez monsieur je vous ai
entendu et vous avez raison on peut pas
on a pas les moyens mais quand il y en a
un qui est surveillé si le gars et vous
et vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs le gars il
va pas être idiot au point au téléphone
il va raconter ce qu'il va faire dans
les 2hures qui suit donc on arrive à les
prendre il y a à peu près un attentat
qui est déjoué tous les mois en France
un attentat qui est déjoué tous les mois
en France on peut pas dire que nos
services de renseignement ne sont pas
efficaces après Jérôme GED l'a rappelé
le risque zéro n'existe pas ceux qui
vous dirit ça mentent c'est pas possible
on va essayer de parler des enseignants
on a beaucoup parler de la question
sécuritaire euh lors de notre précédent
débat je vais vous faire écouter tiens
votre collègue euh Madame Agnès Carel
députée horizon enseignante de
profession c'était un peu plusut tôt
dans l'après-midi dans l'hémicycle nous
enseignants sommes des sentinelles de la
République et de la démocratie c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous sommes visés
au travers des professeurs de France ce
sont tous les professeurs du monde qui
se battent dans la transmission de la
philosophie des
Lumières voilà et le rassemblement
national demande la démission de Gérald
haranin dès ce soir est-ce que c'est le
bon moment est-ce que c'est la bonne
temporalité pour votre parti alors qu'on
est tous abattu choqué par cette par
cette émotion qui n qui nous mais vous
savez il faut pas il faut faut pas faut
pas mélanger les deux bien sûr qu'il y a
de l'émotion par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé à race bien sûr que quand on
entend cette collègue on ne peut pas ne
pas être touché par ce qu'elle dit vous
savez moi j'ai été policier pendant 22
ans Ahed merabé je le connaissais très
bien Exavier jugelet je le connaissais
très bien également ils ont tous les
deux tous les deux été tués pendant
Charlie Hebdo et sur les
champsélysé faut savoir que notre pays
est gangrainé par l'idéologie islamiste
depuis de nombreuses années il y a deux
choses qui m'ont marqué dans ma carrière
la première c'était le 11 septembre 2001
les attentats de New York avec le W
train Center ou dans de nombreux sites
té française des dizaines de jeunes
étaient contents ceondé vive Ben Laden
bientôt ce sera votre tour ça c'est ce
que j'ai vécu c'est du réel c'est de la
vraie vie ensuite en 2009 j'ai j'ai
discuté avec des policiers algériens qui
me disaient vous savez le problème de la
France c'est que vous avancez les yeux
bandés avec une auréole sur la tête
pendant que les islamistes ils avancent
avec leur kalashnikov et leur idéologie
et malheureusement vous ne voyez rien et
vous ne faites rien qu'est-ce que vous
proposez alors vousè d'abord d'abord je
je rappelle que l'idéologie islamiste le
fondamentalisme on peut combattre une
idéologie doit être mais oui mais à
partir du moment où vous avez des
étrangers qui viennent sur le territoire
national pour imposer leur culture leur
identité et quand ils veulent détourner
le loi de la République pour notamment
faire appliquer les lois de la charia
oui c'est un problème je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le risque zéro certes
n'existe pas mais il faut faire ce qu'il
faut pour essayer de s'en rapprocher le
alors concrètement qu'est-ce que vous
proposez d'abord il faut lutter contre
l'idéologie islamiste je rappelle que
Marine Le Pen en 2021 avait déposé une
proposition de loi pour combattre
l'idéologie islamiste notamment les
subventions pour certaines associations
qui défendent
euh l'islam radical ensuite il faut
expulser les étrangers délinquants et
notamment les fichiers s radicalisé
étranger il y en a effectivement plus de
4000 sur les oui mais oui d'accord il
faut s'en occuper mais vous savez il
faut appliquer ce que font 95 % des pays
du monde moi j'ai travaillé énormément
au prochorient mais vous pensez que dans
les pays notamment l'Égypte euh les
Émirats Arab Unis vous pensez qu'il
gardent les étrangers radical is sur le
territoire mais ils sont emprisonnés ils
sont expulsés pourquoi en France nous ne
faisons pas la même chose je pense que
nous avons eu la main molle et
aujourd'hui malheureusement nous en
payons le prix pire connais ça je me
souviens d'une d'une proposition c'était
natthalie kochusco Moriset qui qui
l'avançait interdire le salafisme je
sais pas si vous vous en souvenez est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'on peut parvenir à à à à
des textes à des mesures pour que un
certain nombre de prédicateurs qui
incitent à la haine appel à la violence
dans certaines mosquées notamment
n'existe plus dans notre pays oui je
crois qu'on peut en tout cas essayer de
d'expulser un certain nombre de
prédicateurs mais c'est évidemment ça
pose une question de droit pénal puisque
effectivement silappelle à la prière
l'appel à la dénonciation des mécrayants
ne se traduit pas par aller à les
assassinés on considère au regard de la
loi que c'est de la liberté d'expression
on a eu plusieurs cas comme celui-là moi
je voudrais revenir sur les le
parallélisme entre les deux affaires si
vous voulez enzorov et Dominique Bernard
famille ten famille ingouche peu importe
c'est les mêmes c'est la même filiation
si vous voulez ethnique tous les deux
acceptés parce que persécutés par les
Russes parce que persécuté par les
Russes on vérifie pas si sont des
démocrates non ce sont pas des victimes
et cetera dans le cas en zorov c'est
d'autant plus paradoxal que dans un
premier temps la la CNDA avait refusé
parce que ils sont tellement habitués à
entendre le même discours venant des
chechenin qui sont préparés par les ONG
droit de lomiste que à la fin avec
anzorov il dis celui-là il a vraiment
pas travaillé son texte donc voyez il y
avait eu un refus parce que la seule FA
che et de raconter la même histoire
10000 fois à la fin il commence par se
méfier dans le cas effectivement de
cette famille là aussi on était sous le
cas d'une procédure d'expulsion or on ne
fait rien c'est-à-dire on applique une
loi mais en fait s'il vous plaît
voulez-vous bien quitter le territoire
français je veux dire c'est incroyable
de de prendre des mesure comme ça
deuxième remarque
le rappelez-vous la fin de l'affaire
Samuel Patti donc le jeune anzorov est
tué par la police son père le félicite
et ensuite ils repartent en tchenéie
donc il y a bien une question de droit
d'asile si vous voulez qu'on a appliqué
d'une manière incroyablement laxy sans
se demander si les gens qui arrivaient
sur le territoire étaient dangereux et
on retrouve le même scénario ici en se
disant non non mais il sont des victimes
et puis ensuite une fois qu'on les a sur
le ventre ben on les garde et donc la
dernière remarque c'est que ce sont les
musulmans républicains qui sont la
principale détestation de ces salafistes
tous ceux qui prennent position pour la
République sont considérés comme des
cibles aujourd'hui et cela aussi il faut
les protéger donc vous rendez compte
qu'on est dans un dispositif policier
statique parce qu'on veut pas avoir une
politique active donc voilà moi je me
contente de conclure comme ça je
voudrais qu'on revienne un instant aux
enseignants les signes allementands vous
êtes au conseil des sages de la laïcité
on entendait dire que ça marchait pas
forcément alors expliquez-nous comment
sont organisé les les remontées du
terrain qui peuvent aboutir à une alerte
et même parfois à la décision si je ne
dis pas de bêtises du ministre de
l'éducation nationale d'interdire les
les abayas à parttir d'un certain nombre
de signalements oui alors bon ce sont
généralement les chefs d'établissement
qui font remonter par une application
qui s'appelle fait établissement les
problèmes qu'ils peuvent rencontrer les
les les les les situations
conflictuelles qu'ils peuvent rencontrer
quelquefois dans la classe des
contestations des contenus
d'enseignement quelquefois à d'autres
moments à l'interclasse à la cantine
quelquefois lors de sorties scolaires et
cetera donc ces signalement remontent et
son
généralement traité par les équipes
académiques qui ont été mises en place
déjà depuis 2018 donc il y a un certain
nombre de personnes qui sont de de de
professionnels de l'éducation qui sont
dévoués à cette tâche c'est-à-dire de
d'interveniron suffment il y en a
suffisamment je crois qu'il y en a
suffisamment aujourd'hui c'est quelque
chose qui est allé en augmentant nous
avons eu une réunion récemment nationale
de tous les les référents ce qu'on
appelle dans nos jargons impossibles
référents académique valeur de la
République et laïcité
bon on a des des des personnes des
personnels qui sont très engagés alors
qu'est-ce qui vous marque le plus sur
ces signalements aujourd'hui parce qu'on
a l'impression qu'on demande tellement
aux professeurs qu'il ne peuvent
plus répondre à ces demandes sociales
qui ne sont pas de l'ordre de
l'éducation nationale sur un certain
nombre de cours sur des
tenues et j'en passe sur la transmission
des valeurs de la République la laïcité
et cetera mais je vais vous prendre je
vais prendre le dernier exemple dont
tout le monde a entendu parler vous vous
l'avez citez vous-même c'est concernant
les abayas bon les abayas il faut le
savoir les premières que nous avons vu à
l'éducation nationale ça date de
2010-21 les compte il y a un moment
c'était dans un lycée à saintouin et
quand elles sont apparues le premier
réflexe de l'institution malheureusement
il est souvent pas le bon premier
réflexe a été de dire attention c'est
c'est pas un problème c'est pas cultuel
c'est culturel faut voir ça ce sont des
jeunes filles ben on le sait que ce sont
des jeunes filles on parle a il faut
dialoguer on on passe notre temps dans
les établissements à dialoguer mais le
dialogue précisément comme le rappelle
nos textes le ministre Gabriel àal l'a
encore rappelé dans sa note de service
le 31 août dernier le dialogue ça n'est
pas la négociation bien entendu donc le
premier réflex avait été ça donc on a
désarmé les professeurs qui disaient on
ne veut pas des abayas dans nos classes
les jeunes filles qu'on voulait pas voir
dans la classe c'est le la tenue qu'elle
portait puis on leur a dit non non faut
faut pas y toucher faut savoir que dès
ce moment-là derrière les jeunes filles
qui portaient cet ABA au lycée de
Saint-Ouin il y avait un homme qui s'est
illustré des années après
de dans l'assassinat de Samuel pati
c'est abdelakim Sefrioui qui est en
prison aujourd'hui c'est lui qui était
devant le LCÉE de Saint-Ouin avec des
banderoles
disant hurlant contre voilà la
répression et ceera l'islamophobie et
cetera et cetera donc c'était
rappelez-nous ce cet imam ou ce
prédicateur qui avait accomp
voilàétaitit pass pourélève qui avait
qui nétait pas dans la classe mais qui
avait voilà qui sétait fait passer pour
long pour accompagner il s'était déjà
fait passer pour un oncle en en 2010 à
Saint-Ouin il avait l'habitude bon tout
ça pour vous dire que aujourd'hui le
ministre Gabriel Atal a su réagir
laabaya le camis il a su les nommer
quelques jours avant la rentrée c'est
interdit et aujourd'hui je peux vous
dire que dans l'éducation nationale on
en parle plus je veux dire il y en a
plus qui se présente il y en a eu ça
c'est on commence à se à réarmer la
République
in qui s'exprime sur une chaîne
concurrente ce soir je vous le signale
fait explique qu'il y a bien un lien
entre le conflit au proche- Orient et il
y aurait alors c'est ce qui il y a du
conditionnel dans sa bouche entre cet
attentat d'aras et ce qui se passe au
Proche Orient ça veut dire que vous vous
craignez j'imagine que ça ne soit pas le
dernier le grand chef du Hamas qui est
en à l'étranger qui n'est plus dans la
bande de Gaza vous doutez bien il est
dans un hôtel luxueux au Qatar avait
appel à une journée aujourd'hui
d'attentat jour de colère oui jour de
colère parce que c'est la journée de
prière aussi des musulmans à frapper
partout sur le territoire européen donc
on s'attendait enfin on s'attendait
c'est terrible de dire ça mais il y
avait un risque effectivement qu'il y
ait quelque chose vous ditomilienne à un
enseignant qui a peur aujourd'hui après
ce qui s'est passé et qui ne veut pas
faire 7 minutes de silence lundi dans
son collège à la mémoire de Samuel Patti
est-ce que vous le comprenez ou est-ce
que vous lui appelez au sursut comprend
non je le comprends parce je comend mais
en tant que Fils de prof on en a discuté
un petit peu avant de venir sur le
plateau je le comprends mais faut qu'il
le fasse faut vraiment qu'il le fasse on
a trop longtemps pas nommeré les choses
vous le rappeliez on n pas nomé les
choses alors c'est facile moi je vais
dans les établissements moi des profs me
remercie quand je vais parler de laïcité
quand je vais parler de harcèlement le
harcèlement c'est un autre problème mais
quand je vais parler de laïcité j'essaie
de comprendre pourquoi c'est plus simple
pour moi mais c'est plus simple pour moi
pour une raison simple c'est que je vais
passer une heure ou de 2h dans les dans
l'établissement après c'est fini h h je
je ne cours pas je je je n'ai pas grand
risque à le faire alors je vous donne la
parole dans un tout petit instant mais
on va aller voir Marco Pomier devant le
le lycée Gambetta d'Arras Marco
justement les enseignants qui ont subi
cette cette journée de de deuil comment
vivent-il tout
ça ben écoutez Miriam c'était pas
évident de parler à ses enseignants cet
après-midi d'accéder jusqu'à eux à cause
d'un important périmètre re de sécurité
mais ce qu'on peut vous dire ce soir
c'est que le proviseur de la cité
scolaire Gambetta carnaau a pris une
décision symbolique il a annoncé la
réouverture de l'établissement en tout
cas pour les enseignants et les élèves
qui le souhaitent on imagine bien que ce
ne sera pas une journée tout à fait
normale une décision saluée par Emmanuel
Macron une belle preuve que la nation
fait bloc contre l'obscurantisme a dit
le chef de l'État alors cet après-midi
on a quand même pu discuter avec un ense
ignant qui s'interrogeait car vous le
savez myiam l'assaillant était un ancien
élève de cet établissement et cet
enseignant me disait qu'est-ce qu'on a
raté avec lui on a échoué on n pas
réussi à l'immuniser contre ce genre de
dérive il nous faut trouver des
solutions merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS
Marco
Pomier à votre avis Michel taverne vous
vous vous avez des des enfants dans une
école aujourd'hui vous dites quoi il
faut faire ce travail de mémoire pour
Samuel paatti vous allez essayer de
convaincre le professeur parce
qu'aujourd'hui jeen suis sûr il y en a
beaucoup qui ont peur il a énormément vu
le climat je rappelle que Géral d'Anin a
expliqué avait sans doute je mets des
guillemets un lien entre ce qui se passe
au proche- Orient et cette attentat ça
va être très compliqué lundi vous leur
dites quoi aux
enseignants je leur dis peut-être de
faire ce qu'ils ont envie de faire les
laisser libre de leur choix bien
évidemment je pense qu'il ne faut pas
leur imposer quelque chose ils sont
suffisant responsable suffisamment grand
pour faire ce dont ils ont envie mais
vous savez le malaise dans
l'enseignement date déjà depuis
plusieurs années il y a bien évidemment
ces actes ignobles Samuel paatti
aujourd'hui ce professeur à à haras mais
c'est tous les jours je rappelle que
dans un dernier sondage il y avait
quasiment 60 % des enseignants qui
s'autocensuraient pour éviter de de
polémiquer sur une religion une
civilisation auto censuré et il y a un
manque d'enseignant dans l'éducation
nationale pourquoi c'est comme dans les
forces de l'ordre c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on a plus forcément confiance en l'état
on a plus forcément confiance au
gouvernement qui se sont succédés depuis
30 ans et aujourd'hui on en paye le prix
mais clairement aujourd'hui et vous avez
raison de le
dire l'école de la République est un
sanctuaire c'est un sanctuaire on voit
que l'islam politique est essaie
d'entrer dans cette dans ce sanctuaire
notamment avec des salles de prière avec
la BAA c'est notre collègue Roger chudo
qui avait déposé une proposition de loi
pour interdire la BAA la majorité s'y
est opposée donc aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas dire Gabriel Atal a pris le a pris
le taureau par les cornes il faut
prendre des mesures mais mais je suis
désolé mais sur différents sujets sur
l'immigration sur la sécurité sur sur la
laïcité mais au rassemblement national
mais on a un cècle d'avance sur vous
excusez-moi il faut prendre des mesures
aujourd'hui qui vont dans le bon sens
les hommages certes c'est bien mais ce
que veulent les Français aujourd'hui ce
sont des actes concrets d'un mot je vais
donner la la le mot de la fin rapidement
à l'enseignant vous êtes à l'insexique
les recteurs les syndicats d'enseignants
sont avec Gabriel ce soir qu'est-ce que
vous attendez du ministre très
concrètement ben très concrètement qu'il
continue dans la voix qu' qu'il s'est
tracé qu'il dise bien à quelle hauteur
doit être la réponse de l'institution
scolaire la peur que vous évoquiez de
certains enseignants elle n'est pas
illégitime évidemment on peut la
comprendre mais c'est collectivement que
nous devons nous montrer tous plus fort
que cette peur on s'arrête sur cette
note d'optimisme on ne saura laffaire
sefriwi que s'il est expulséz c'est fin
ça il est en prison oui il doit être
jugé avant merci beaucoup c'est voilà
une journée lourde merci d'être venu
débattre sur LCP en direct on va et
Merci à VOUS Marco Pomier évidemment
depuis aras on va se quitter en image
regardez les colonnes de l'Assemblée
illuminé aux couleurs tricolore du du
drapeau français voilà évidemment en
hommage à tous à tous les enseignants
qui ont peur aujourd'hui et qui se
battent pour les valeur de la République
et puis bien sûr en hommage aux victimes
aux blessés d'aras après cet attentat
effroyable très belle soirée sur LCP
soirée documentaire avec Jean-Pierre
Gratien à la semaine
[Musique]
prochaine